hey guys it's and welcome to the channel
today we're going to be looking in on
the DIY bin and the topic that we're
going to deal with today is three things
that can make you more successful in
being a worm farmer
where you may have had problems before
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at those three things and then
we're going to kind of unpack them
number one is being impatient number two
is making it way too complicated and
number three is loving your worms three
loving your worms too much so as we're
going through and doing the maintenance
on my DIY bin we will go ahead and talk
about those topics
so it's been about three weeks since
we've looked in on this and so we're
just going to kind of look around and
see what we've done I think we fed on
the second layer down
and we're just going to kind of look at
this it was refreshed uh I'll put how
long ago it was refreshed in the window
there
so you can tell this is actually really
new this has got a lot of cardboard to
it and also has a lot of the coconut
core in there
so this is nowhere near you know
migrating or anything like that but
we're going to start with topic number
one which is being impatient so when you
first start being a worm farmer you
start a new bin
the expectations that people have that
the the new bin or when you're a new
farmer just new in general is that
basically
um your worms are going to work as fast
as anybody else's
and that's just not true when you first
have a worm bin and you just start it
and you make your bedding and you put
your worms in there and you hear all of
the stories that one pound of worms or
half a kilo will eat that much in food
every day or every week or whatever the
story is that is totally not true
I've been doing this for you know quite
a few years now and I just don't find
that to be true in my situation maybe
there's some situation out there where
it is true but it is not here
so basically if you're going to expect
those worms to eat uh their body weight
every day then you are going to end up
with a big mess and probably dead worms
and a lot of stinkiness
so we don't you know do not accept that
do not do not be impatient and try and
Rush your worms into eating too much
food you need to always evaluate what
the worms are doing and then let them be
your guide if there's no food left then
you feed them more if there's a lot of
food left don't feed them
and also you know if they uh appear to
be as far as moisture goes just don't
assume that they need to be sopping wet
because they breathe through their skin
so they need air as well so if
everything is soft and wet you know then
the worms might also not be happy so
don't get impatient and just think that
uh you follow all of the little things
you hear on Facebook
all right so let's look at the next
layer down I will admit when I first
started making worm bins and having worm
farm I will admit that I was impatient
and I really thought that I was gonna
you know save the world from you know
all of the the garbage and my worms were
going to take care of it all and the
reality versus my expectations were not
aligned as it turns out you know when
your worm farm is new you know you get
impatient to put all of this food in
here and then as it turns out you really
need an ecosystem in your worm bins in
order to take care of that much food and
so when you don't have the springtails
and the mites and the roly-polies and
everything else as far as bacteria and
fungus in your worm bin then it's not
going to operate as quickly so you do
have to wait about almost six months for
the biology to catch up with your
expectations I think we did
feet on this side over here
actually don't remember what it was I
think it was
soup stuff so I did say that the uh the
slow food was going to be the the potato
peels and I think I can smell onion in
here but I don't I don't see it oh there
it is there's the tomato or the onion
end and
I'll try and hold it still
but there are springtails in there I
don't know if I see anything else other
than worms and springtails I don't see
any mice but if I hold still long enough
maybe I can do a time lapse and we'll be
able to see it
okay so then looking at the other food
or looking for the other food rather
then yeah I'm just seeing that potato so
far that's all I'm seeing so they've
they've eaten everything else I'll have
to put a picture up there of what all we
did feed them but the only evidence I'm
seeing is that onion and the potato
which is trying to grow
long time of the year dude
Okay so
the second point that I wanted to get to
is that new worm Farmers make it overly
complicated I know I did so when I made
this bin you know I assumed it had to
have three layers and it had to have a
lid and screen and and that I couldn't
feed you know onions and tomatoes
because it would you know hurt the worms
and what it turns out too is there's a
lot of urban legends
um as Patrick would say and basically
you know they're not people they're not
dogs they don't have the same you know
wants and likes and and skin that we do
so you know I had all these things that
I was like not feeding the worms and had
to go drag outside but as it turns out
you can feed worms onion and green
pepper and tomatoes you know you just
have to like any other food you have to
watch how much you feed them versus how
many worms you have and the only way you
know how often to feed is to look and
see is the food gone nope don't feed
all right bottom level okay so here we
are at the bottom level and uh looks
like it's doing great look at that it's
good worms
love that last time it was kind of dry
and uh didn't look like it was meat you
know making too much progress down here
but they have really done a good job
once I added that water
you know and that's another point is
that uh you know just paying attention
to what's going on in your worm bin is
is worth everything
um because number you know number three
is on your you know to-do list here is
to not aggravate your worms too much so
you can love your worms to death and one
of the ways that you can do that is by
looking in on them twice a day feeding
them too much food
um
some worms are very fussy and they do
not like to have people peeking at them
all the time
and that is one of the problems that you
can have is that if you're in that bin
you know twice a day once a day you can
spook them and certain types of worms
will try to crawl the wall and Escape if
you pester them too much and also by
loving them too much you can give them
too much food I'm going to give them a
little bedding down here because it
looks like they're they are in need so
that's rule one evaluate and then act
so I'm just going to give them a little
sprinkle of new bedding down here just
to give them something to work on I'm
not really sure if the worms come from
this bottom level up all right let's put
the second
row back up okay so
this is our our second level and we fed
a little bit and it does have a little
bit left so I'm just going to switch
sides over here and I'm going to give
them a little bit more of kind of the
same food
basically stuff I made soup with some
avocados
I think this is a tomato
yeah it's all wrinkly so just some slow
food there and one little piece of fast
food
and that should keep this layer going
good for quite some time I'm going to
give them a little bit of extra bedding
on this side just to keep it level
okay
that just kind of keeps it from
kiltering
all right we're back on the top layer
here and uh since we fed over here on
that second layer I think I'm going to
do the feeding over on this side just so
that the drippings can go down evenly
and the um the good stuff can get picked
up by the worms in the bottom
and I'm going to give them a really big
mix of slow and fast food here so that
they will have enough for the next three
weeks these are apples not frozen some
of them are frozen so they're going to
last probably a month maybe even two
let's grab that sticker
so even though this looks like a lot of
food this is a lot of slow food they
might be able to nibble most of this
banana away but for the most part this
is going to be in here the next time we
visit the worms so I hope that all of
these tips were helpful to you to learn
how to you know not love your worms to
death and also don't don't restrict
yourself to so many rules and make
everything so complicated
and then hopefully that'll give you also
a little bit of an idea that you do need
to be patient and don't pester your
worms too often and expect them to be
eating their weight in food every single
day or week if you like this bin the DIY
bin I have a playlist that is right over
there also if you don't want to watch
that YouTube thinks you're going to like
this video right over here alright guys
thanks for hanging out with me and my
worms and everybody have a good day